I want to walk where Marilyn Monroe
walked and I want a pushy
who did you John F Kennedy one of them
Mafia man yeah
you know people go to her um
[Music]
a Rhode Island state senator was
arrested in Cranston last week which I
guess is a place in Rhode Island
because he heated car he was he was
caught on footage a car you get arrested
for that Rhode Island arrests people for
that [__] because a guy had a Biden
sucks bumper sticker
so he was abidance of the Biden
supporter Mega fan and he keyed it he
keyed the guy's car he sees the bumper
sticker you can see him go by the car
and he looks at it and then he [__]
takes his keys out wow he's a car
there's a guy in the car the guy sees
him and he's like he opens the door he's
like did you just [__] key my car and
then the state center is like no with
the keys in his hand the keys yeah
huh no he drops the keys he then he goes
into you know the wherever the [__] they
are right
Cranston the Cranston and the guy calls
the cops and then the guy's like inside
for a while the cops go in they talk to
him and then he's like oh no I didn't
key the guy's car you can see here's my
keys look there's no paint on the on
that because he went
but there's no pain what a fun cat dude
and then he starts saying that the guy
has been harassing him so then he had to
key his car so he had to key his car to
make the de-escalate the situation so I
had to keep so I had to key his car but
I didn't key his car yeah yeah I had to
key his car because he was confronting
me because he's obsessed with me he
knows who I am and they're like dude
this is all they have all this on body
this guy's not good at that no he's not
good at it he cracked Under Pressure
you're like you don't he doesn't know
who you are he he clearly didn't know
who you were he was like why did you
keep my car he wasn't talking to you
knowing your name or anything like that
sir but this guy was like adamant that
he was innocent and he had to key the
car to de-escalate you see how he goes
to like victim mode you know like well
he was [__] with me so I had to do
that it's like that doesn't work it's
not de-escalation exactly in his world I
had to key it for because because like
um I had to stop him yeah he says the
guy was blocking my way saying that I
scratched his car I didn't scratch his
car I'm a state senator I think he
recognized me I think he's one of the
gun nuts
that's what he said that sounds like
he's escalating all of it yeah yeah
then then he asked that the officers
arrest him talk to a
um a guy in the department because he
knows people in the police he's like you
should talk to that guy because he'll
tell you that I've reported these
threats from this guy before and they
looked into it and they're like nothing
nothing dude this guy's such a
politician he's a politician bro wow he
got connections all over a great future
but not good connections because he got
arrested good um yeah the other guy
didn't collaborate because he was like I
don't know imagine just shrugging
through this whole thing listening to
another guy make up a whole story is
that considered a good politician if you
just like bring up points that can be
easily disproved yeah yeah
that's true he's really in line with
kind of all of them yeah damn he's
representing pretty well did you see
that Senators can be bought for like ten
thousand dollars like you can Lobby
their opinion yeah that's their lobbying
price but 10 000 in Gifts of some sort
right like tuition for their kids or
donations I don't know how it's done but
the this black rock recruiter was like
on a date and just spilling all this
[__] and then like he was just like yes
and senators are cheap they're like 10
000 and then so if you have like half a
million they'll do anything you want
and I'm like suck a dick are you [__]
kidding me dude I believe it honestly
that is so cheap yeah yeah I was like
that's that's all it takes to buy out
one of these folks it's like
wow think about what the politicians
always do right they're always on TV and
they're always like just give us a 20 30
donation and [__] like that we know they
don't give a [__] about us because they
don't do anything for the people giving
the 20 30 donation they do it for the
big boys giving the real money that's
why people are like oh these politicians
they never [__] do anything for us
it's like yeah because it's worth it to
do something for the banks or whoever's
gonna give them money way more they're
way more incentive yeah if they do
things for us and honor then kind of a
thankless job in it they don't yeah
they're not gonna make anything it's
almost like it was set up for them to be
bribed it's just like uh you guys ever
get your car painted before no so the
the hack what you do you don't pay the
[__] paint shop you find the guy
who's gonna do it and you go I'm gonna
tip you like 200 bucks and then he'll
just do a whole extra he'll give you the
best paint he'll do two clear coats
because you're paying him directly if I
ever need to get my my car painted can
you come with me and negotiate for me
with me I'll be like [__] this kid's car
up bro yeah yeah so you go to the shop
but you talk to them you find the
Mexican dude that's really gonna do it
oh yeah you go to the back because
they're not you could just walk back
there but what if the shop owner is
going to be like wait whose car is this
well the shot the it's not the owner's
never there it's the the person who does
the adjusting or who like will do the
paperwork they don't care either
sometimes they tell you to do that what
other [__] do you know but I like to
announce I like to announce my
intentions when I enter a space so I'd
probably walk in and I'd be like hello
I'm looking for the paint gun and not
the owner I don't want to talk to you
yeah that's how I'm gonna go around him
that's how we would do it at Mako or one
day Paint like they would because back
then if you go like they'll be like oh
just talk to this guy yeah yeah and then
you go to the back and you go hey man
what's up I'm gonna get this done or I
want to put this installed it'll go yeah
just give it to me dude we got a family
friend that does it on the weekends of
like car he needs to fix anything on the
car like Bodywork like I remember one
time we had a cracked bumper and I was
like hey
can you fix this for me he goes like
I'll do this for 300 and he came to the
house and you just [__] did it it was
[__] sweet oh yeah he came to your
house to do it yeah bro he was the man
did he just like put in some gum [__] he
just punched it and it popped out and I
was like oh good that [__] works
sometimes no but he like he I I was
looking at the bumper and I was like I
don't know how the [__] you're gonna fix
this but then it came back brand
spanking you baby just Jack some other
guys
I need to do a catalytic converter baby
he just took off theirs put yours on
yeah is it two different colors yes he
put your rear bumper in the front
dude my buddy my buddy's hubcap my
buddy's such a [__] Boston scumbag
masshole we're driving on in his Mustang
and he thought his Mustang was so sick
it's just a [__] basic basic ass
Mustang right base model Mustang and his
hubcap like rolls off in the middle of
the freeway and then we when we get to
where we're going he like drives through
a shopping center and then he sees him
Mustang he gets out he steals her
[__] hubcap oh my God
damn dude middle of the day that is so
trash
yikes Mass hole Patriots fans scumbags
Red Sox fan Sports motivated crimes are
hilarious motivated but no the so the
cops are basically saying he he was
arraigned he was released on a thousand
dollar Bond he's due back in court for a
rearrangement they're saying nobody's
Above the Law including those who make
and enforce the laws the officers who
handled this investigation did so with
fairness
um and it was all on body cams too dude
Rhode Island's tough on crime huh
apparently maybe this guy's got no juice
as a politician so he's not powerful
enough and everyone's like that [__]
guy again everybody's not Hunter Biden I
know right it sounds senile
trying to pull here is just to make the
situation so hard to navigate that the
cop just goes all right just [__] get
out of here guys you know what I mean
like they just try to make it a nuisance
because that's what they do here you
know like a cop like if this happened
here the copper go are you hurt are you
injured no and you're okay all right
just go home both of you yeah that's
usually what happens but once they keyed
your car though
you gotta pay for that in L.A they don't
care about nothing is that is that why
you moved
that's what I've been telling you
is that why all you guys moved yeah half
the room so Reno huh yeah
is it
look I love Vegas but the Reno side of
Tahoe it's pretty cool Lake Tahoe I
never been it's beautiful it's nice big
ass [__] Lake Joseph skeptical and
then there's [__] like casinos around
it so imagine like Yosemite giant Lake
and then casinos around it that's what I
want in my nature this is a south side
of Lake Tahoe the Reno side yeah pretty
cool dude you know that one hotel where
all the Mobsters went where it's like
California on one side
Nevada on the other and it's on the
border and they have tunnels and stuff
and apparently like Marilyn Monroe and
all them used to like use that [__] to
like go to other rooms and buck and
whatever that's cool yeah what about it
I want to go there oh cool okay okay
I want to walk where Marilyn Monroe
walked and you wanna [__] where she
[__] I want to [__] who she [__] who
she [__] who did she [__] John F
Kennedy one of them
Mafia man yeah
laughs you know people go to her um they
go to where she's like in order she's
like in the wall what do you call that
they shove my glory hole no no where's
she buried oh like Mausoleum yeah yeah I
think it's glorial you guys glory hole
what the [__] I think that's what you're
thinking of I swear that was hurt back
there on the other side do you touch it
yeah you touch it people touch it they
come they put lipstick on they kiss it
ew so it has like this Rouge color to it
it's supposed to be like white marble
but it has a Rouge color to it because
they constantly clean it people
constantly are kissing it do you think
Marilyn Monroe in heaven is just like yo
what the [__] are you guys doing yeah
her spirit's like my Mausoleum and
apparently and I don't know if this is
true or not but this is a true like one
of those true Tall Tales of Hollywood
Hugh Hefner
got the tomb above her or whatever and
then he made sure that he's upside down
in there so when he's dead he could face
so they could be like that yeah because
that was like his dream chick or
whatever
so I'm being serious is that why he kept
going for blondes because he was trying
to like make Marilyn Monroe clones
that's his type for sure if you go to um
the Army museum in Paris is two stories
and Napoleon's tomb is in between
because he wanted it the people on the
first floor to have to look up at him
and then the people at the top floor
have the bow whoa so his is like it's
his his tomb is like suspended between
two floors oh that yeah it's tight but
also it's like
you're a little crazy that's a small
man's thing though that's a really tiny
boy that's a five egg thing yeah I'm
five eight so that's that's like [__]
mentally 411 [__] this coffin was for 11
I think was it I could have just crammed
him in there huh he's a little fella
they cut him off by the knees
well everyone says that he's actually
not that yeah he's actually like an
advertising he's an average height why
do they make fun of him being short
because uh they measured it in French
inch which is well it's different from
English inch I guess oh interesting so
then when when they converted it it was
small but I think they've just been
roasting just full of the ass you know
what I I think he's like
411. I think he just has hella haters
yeah yeah
that's just bad branding
[Music]